most games and movies get grenades wrong
whether it's tactically cooking a frag
in Call of Duty action heroes like our
knee and slide pulling pins with their
teeth or the huge fireballs be seeing
classic blockbusters like commando or
more recently in the Fast and Furious
franchise games and movies have totally
over-exaggerated the humble grenade
while there is a grain of truth to have
games and movies depict handheld
explosives
most of these depictions are blown way
out of proportion so that begs the
question where does the truth end and
the action movie trope begin rudimentary
grenades and hand thrown explosives have
been around since a time of the
Byzantine Empire around the mid 700 BC
the first modern hand grenade however
was the mills bomb that was issued to
frontline British troops fighting in the
First World War it resembles many
fragmentation grenades that you may see
in today's popular culture with its
notched and raised edges colloquially
known as a pineapple pattern while these
explosive things have existed in one
form or another for hundreds of years
it's undoubtedly the frags we see and on
modern movies and games today that had a
cultural touchstone we are all familiar
with so to get the story on how grenades
work in the real world I caught up with
the Royal Armouries keeper of firearms
artillery Jonathan Ferguson on the
general side how does a real grenade
work so you've got a cast metal body
you've got your high explosive content
filler
you've got your fuse that is now stuck
in from the top and then attached the
top of that is this lever which is
holding down this spring-loaded striker
and of course the iconic pin that goes
through that leave and holds it in place
you pull out the pin which frees up the
lever when you let go of it the striker
itself typically throws the lever away
from the grenade at which point you
really do need to let go of it because
what's happened is that striker has
flipped over under spring pressure slap
the percussion cap just like in a
firearm cartridge and that fuse is now
burning down to the middle where the
splode e stuff is that exploding stuff
is what has led to a number of tropes
and misconceptions to be associated with
the grenade chief among these is the
fiery explosion that accompanies one
going boom
follow closely by those in the blasts
being tossed around like origami action
figures this whole grenades throwing
chaps around like they're made of paper
mache has been a long-running trend and
that exists in modern movies and games
lobbing one of these towards a group of
bad guys is an easy excuse for a movie
to cut some an explosion and immediately
eject some over-the-top action into any
set piece
it was always entertaining to watch
classic action films like commando on a
Rambo franchise and see bad guys flung
into the next continent by a fiery blast
that came from something smaller than
the protagonists fist in reality however
the end result was much less cinematic
in reality because what's happening is
the explosive fracturing the casing and
sending the case fragments flying
through the air all you see you might
glimpse a flash but what you typically
see if you watch the videos is a puff of
smoke quite a big puff of smoke what you
can't see are the deadly fragments
flying out you know within the sort of
50 meter effective range of a typical
hand grenade they're more than enough to
go through your body or into your body
and kill you and there's also a blast
effect there's not enough of a blast
effect to fling you through the air so
yeah it's it's pretty anticlimactic when
you actually see these things go off
aside from the common fiery blast we see
in our entertainment there are a handful
of tropes that have become key quotes or
tactics and games the ability to cooked
grenade has been around in games for
over a decade with players on 2005 day
of defeat sauce forums discussing how to
drop grenades at your feet pick them up
later and throw them again with a
shorter timer obviously very aware of
how advantageous and only explosion can
be the core strategy when it comes to
cooking your needs and games is to cut
the enemy's response time be that the
time it takes for them to run away or
throw the thing back at you and while
cooking your grenade means you can't
wield a gun and thus leave you open to
fire for longer taking that risk could
be the difference between clearing a
room and downing an enemy squad while
having your payload returned to sender
in real life however the idea of keeping
a bomb in your hand or even picking one
up there's been unfortunate enough to
land in your vicinity isn't much more
complicated and obviously riskier
venture
your average military-issued
fragmentation grenade is not infallible
as they work on chemical fuses there is
not an exact save time in which you can
hold on to them and depending on what
military is serving or what grenade
you're throwing fuses can vary in timing
and these are just the kind of uncertain
variables you don't want to play with
talking about british and commonwealth
experience so their grenade our grenades
I should say range from three to four
seconds so if you cook a grenade and the
recommended cooked cooking time I don't
know what gas mark are talking about the
recommended cooking time is two seconds
for the American grenade well if you
wait two seconds on a three to four
second delay and either get it wrong or
there's a match slight manufacturing
floor or whatever your grenades gone off
on your hand and we have accounts of
that happening a lot of these this is
medal award time if you're practicing
something like this you've typically
done something to win an award or at
least that's how we hear about it
similarly throwing your grenades back to
the enemy has been a strategy in FPS
games for a while as well with one of
the earliest appearances of the
technique being in day of defeat sauce
and 2006 is Call of Duty 3 it would then
become a mainstay in modern action
titles appearing as a gameplay mechanic
in everything from battlefield to
uncharted interestingly however the
tactic was born from real-life war
stories drain grenades back absolutely
did happen again it's not a tactic that
you can really rely upon because if they
have cooked the grenade or it's been
rattling around on the floor for for a
few seconds the window of time to pick
it up and throw it is limited and yet
there are various accounts of this this
being done but it did happen so I've got
an account here from a captain Martine
Brandtner again United States Marine
Corps this is in Vietnam interestingly
I'm laughing again because he described
this this bit of the battle almost like
a snowball fight he apparently threw
back three grenades in a row and threw
himself on the fourth so in one example
you've got proof that absolutely did
happen and it might happen more than
once pretty much all of these tropes
involving the person using a grenade in
a certain way potentially because it was
medal winning it was picked up by news
and you know feel-good propaganda
and your nap kind of starts the upward
slope of popularity and exposure to it
leaking into entertainment I think
you've hit the missing link there and
that's the news media absolutely the
this these middle citations these
stories from in a wind guys go back to
their hometowns the local papers would
have picked it up we're just so good at
exaggeration and extrapolation aren't we
because it happened once that's how it's
always done so games and movies may
depict grenades in an exaggerated and
unrealistic way but as unrealistic as
the trope may seem there is actually a
grain of truth behind it while cooking a
grenade or throwing an enemy's brain
back might not always be advisable in
the heat of battle those feats have
happened admittedly they happen in
extraordinary circumstances but these
are what make for the most exciting
stories and inspire what can sound like
tall tales and just like in real life
those unbelievable last-second throws
declare a room or exciting videogames
stories to recount - as pieces of
fiction our games and movies allow us to
relive these heroic deeds from the
safety of our own home so it's only
natural that they would exaggerate the
truth to create amazing action
set-pieces
for us to realize there may be no
consistency in the world of film when it
comes to explosions but that's totally
fine because their impacts exist and are
contained within their own genres or
universes and while often a visual
spectacle and games grenade noises
flashes and damage rarely behave
realistically battlefield soldiers being
able to survive a blast just feet away
of them is unrealistic and call of duty
operatives being able to hurl them back
as they blow up barely a couple of
metres away only end up with a ringing
in their ears and jelly on the screen is
pretty ludicrous but for those that want
it there are more realistic digital
portrayals for grenades in games like
armor or escape from tarkov which even
take into consideration individual
pieces of shrapnel are flung around a
room when a grenade goes off
for the most part a game will calculate
the damage dealt to the player based on
their distance from the initial
explosion from lethal at the origin and
less damaging moving outwards in a
sphere of coverage more realistic titles
however will simulate shrapnel patterns
and object penetration to create a much
deadlier and more unpredictable
explosion but again this showcase is the
breadth of utility that the humble
grenade has many games choose to tone
down the damage potential to allow them
to be a tool to reward strategy rather
than a damage dealer take the Call of
Duty series for example and I mean both
the campaign and multiplayer in this
instance I'm sure I've got more kills by
making an enemy move out of position to
flee a grenade than I have with the
actual explosion well in the real world
the objective is to throw your grain in
such a way that the enemy doesn't have
time to react in the virtual one it's
often to gain a positional advantage but
what really allows games the wriggle
room to explore what was possible with a
handheld throwable is that in pop
culture the word grenade is now an
extremely broad term anyone picking up a
game with even the briefest knowledge
about a grenade will know simply that if
I throw this explosion of sorts will
happen and in many ways that's enough it
has been fascinating to learn how
something so dangerous and so volatile
has both changed and inspired our
fiction while also growing into a
virtual entity that nearly every action
game features in some form even thinking
about the bizarre versions of videogame
grenades we see can tell you just how
much they can be co-opted and altered to
fit the narrative and setting of the
most bizarre pieces of fiction be they
the fantastical Borderlands remains that
heal you the ones we find in death
stranding made from Norman Reedus is
poop and blood for the more realistic
and deadly depictions in tarkov of
Rainbow six siege the grenade is a
versatile device that can add a big boom
to your game and even bigger
opportunities for gameplay and action
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
episode of loadout no doubt you've
noticed that this looks a little
different into other episodes that's
because we're all working from home
right now but I hope you still enjoy the
video nonetheless if you did and you
want to see the rest of the series then
you can check out our youtube playlists
and subscribe to our youtube channel so
you don't miss any other episodes and of
course we all here at GameSpot hope that
you're all safe and well in the comfort
of your own homes perfect excuse to stay
inside and play video games right